are you going to u-turn on big measures
further big measures in your mini
budgets as many seem to be speculating
on right now our position hasn't changed
I will come up with the medium-term
fiscal plan on the 31st of October as I
said earlier in the week and there'll be
more detail there
so so what I'm totally focused on is on
delivering on the mini budget making
sure that we get growth back into our
economy and the fact that we're here the
fact that I'm in Washington shows the
nature of the challenge there are
hundreds uh literally hundreds of
officials Finance ministers Central Bank
Governors and they're all tacking the
same questions they're all looking to
see what we can do as a global Community
to deal with inflation what we can do to
deal with Rising interest rates across
the globe and particularly uh very
people are very focused on Energy prices
and the response that we gave in the
mini budget to the energy price
guarantee giving the energy price
guarantee is is really widely
appreciated
responding to the idea there's going to
be a u-turn on corporation tax
is that not a possibility can you
clarify that is it even a possibility
that you're going to you turn on the
corporation my total focus Faisal is on
delivering on the mini budget and making
sure and making sure that we get growth
back into our economy that's the central
prize that's the main focus of my job
and the reason why I'm here in
Washington the reason you're here is
because we've got IMF annuals and
everybody is talking about the same
problems everybody's talking about
energy everybody's talking about
inflation and everybody is talking about
how we can get growth back into the
global economy Chancellor you have a
situation where as you say you've come
here to discuss important issues back
home at number 10 there are discussions
filleting the fiscal statement that you
made just a few
questions
no I speak to uh number 10 I speak to
the Prime Minister all the time and we
are totally focused on delivering the
growth plan I mean what we were facing
was a tax high of 70 years and no growth
and what actually our IMF officials
people I speak to just yesterday uh
christelina georgieva said to me that
growth is a central focus of the
International Community we're quite
right to focus on growth and people are
talking about some of the ideas uh that
we've we've put forward if you had to
uterine a major part of your mini
budgets would you have to consider your
position I'm totally focused on the
growth agenda Faisal I'm totally focused
on making sure that people are helped
with their energy bills that the energy
price guarantee is understood that the
scale of our intervention uh incredible
invertervention of the British state is
understood and that we can actually
deliver this country a path get us on a
trajectory to Growing the economy so
that everyone benefits and actually
what's fascinating to me here is that
this is a these are Global challenges uh
people from the IMF the World Bank the
G7 all of these officials and ministers
are attacking the same problems
knowledge what's the consensus in the
market the bank of England have said it
to which is that there are specific
factors that work at the UK following
your Millions what I am uh going to uh
acknowledge is the fact that it is a
very uh a dicey situation globally
that's what people are saying to me the
people are saying that we do we
understand look there was some
turbulence I I'm Frank enough to accept
that after the minute but but where I'm
sitting here talking about the global
challenges everybody is focused on
inflation everybody is affected by uh
potential interest rate Rises
everybody's affected by the energy price
spikes which have been exacerbated by
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine so
everybody across the Global Financial
Community is really focusing on the same
problems and you'll be Chancellor and
Liz trust will be prime minister this
time next month absolutely 100 I'm not
going anywhere
thank you
I want to speak to our Deputy political
editor Sam coats who was listening to
that interview from Westminster and Sam
the chancellor says he's not going
anywhere wouldn't be drawn on u-turns uh
basically said he's concentrating on
delivering this mini budget and the
growth agenda that sounds a lot
different to what you've been hearing in
Westminster today
that's right Sarah Jane look this is a
fast um and sort of unfolding political
situation so we're having to sort of
re-read the runes quite quite carefully
um it's important to note we actually
start a little bit way into that
interview with quasiquating uh done out
in Washington the jealousy did it has
actually tweeted the beginning the first
question was is there going to be a
U-turn uh and the jealous involved says
that quasiquarting told him our position
hasn't changed I will come up with a
medium-term fiscal plan on the 31st of
October as I said earlier in the week
there'll be more detail on that and then
uh the chancellor went on to answer the
questions that you you you just saw so
it sounds like just before the bit that
you saw the chances are played down if
you're quite ruling out played down
quite strongly the idea that there's a
u-turn on the card but when we faced um
additional when he was challenged with
additional questions he sort of
sidestepped them uh he didn't he he
didn't come down definitively that there
won't be any changes at all he's trying
to hold the line line that there are
going to be no changes until the 31st
but but but it was an uncomfortable
interview and you you could feel that
tension he doesn't want to talk about
the large array of domestic problems he
was there trying to refocus the
interview several times on what was
going on uh overseas he conceded only a
little bit of domestic turbulence um
suggesting the real pain was Global
there is some truth in that but there is
there is also a lot of Truth in the fact
that some of the uh problems that this
government are facing uh with both in
the market and politically are are
completely self-inflicted from the mini
budget that he saw uh three weeks ago
what it seems like to me Sarah Jane is
that there are some in Downing Street
actively looking at undoing some of the
measures in the mini budget but what it
also looks like from everything you
could tell from that interview out in
Washington is that quasi-quarting ain't
happy about that he's playing it down
he's sort of rejecting it but not
perhaps doing so definitively as the
questioner said you know the markets
have already reacted positively to the
idea that there might be some kind of a
view turn I I think that looks like we
can say tensions between the chancellor
and the Prime Minister but there's a lot
more of this that I think is going to
unfold in the coming idea in the coming
hours at Sky News we've been reporting
for a couple of hours there are
discussions in government about which
bits of the mini budget that you could
buy undo potentially the corporation tax
uh uh might be allowed to rise against
something that Liz trusses Johnson to
put a stop to in that money mini budget
three weeks ago uh crazy quieting
defending the principle of low taxation
but not really getting into a defense of
the measures beyond the energy uh tax
hike so Anonymous sources in Westminster
saying one thing the chance of looking
uncomfortable and rejecting some of the
broad themes in Washington which is
having to wait and see what happens
that part of the interview that first
part of the interview you were referring
to we now have that so we're going to
bring that to people stay with us Sam
here's that interview
joining us thank you are you going to
u-turn on big measures further big
measures in your mini budgets as many
seem to be speculating on right now our
position hasn't changed I will come up
with the medium-term fiscal plan on the
31st of October as I said earlier in the
week uh and there'll be more detail
there
is there a possibility that the
corporation tax change so keeping it at
19p won't happen the corporation tax
will be raised so on the cards so what
I'm totally focused on is on delivering
on the mini budget making sure that we
get growth back into our economy and the
fact that we're here the fact that I'm
in Washington uh shows the nature of the
challenge there are hundreds uh
literally hundreds of officials Finance
ministers Central Bank Governors and
they're all tacking the same questions
they're all looking to see what we can
do as a global Community to deal with
inflation and what we can do to deal
with Rising interest rates across the
globe and particularly uh very people
are very focused on Energy prices and
the response that we gave in the mini
budget to the uh energy price guarantee
giving the energy price guarantee is is
really widely appreciated markets
already
um Sam that was the first part of that
interview and quasi-quarting had just
come from a briefing from the IMF where
um the director General had said fiscal
policy should not undermine monetary
policy she was talking about the global
context but honing in on the UK there
quite specifically because what the IMF
have been doing this week is saying look
you know there are Global headwinds
there could be a global recession next
year but looking at the UK this is not
how to deal with it so when you talk
about quasi-karting being uncomfortable
in that interview there he just come
from that straight into some
uncomfortable questions
that's right and I'm just looking down
because I'm just reaching back to what
the IMF managing director actually said
uh and it amounts to a rebuke she said
you don't prolong the pain if the
evidence is that you need a
recalibration is right um it's if the
evidence is that the uh that you need a
recalibration it's right for the
government to do so so he just come from
a meeting with the IMF director who said
if you need to U-turn British government
please do so so yeah uncomfortable out
there but I I think it's important to go
back to what we just saw because there
are some uh including the person who did
the interview who are interpreting
quasiquating's language as a definitive
rejection of the idea that there'd be
any U-turn I I have to say I I thought
it was less definitive than that because
is there going to be U-turn and he said
my position hasn't changed I'll have a
statement on October the 31st then ask
specifically whether it be a u-turn on
corporation tax uh he said I'm focused
on growth that that feels like the
situation is very fluid that's not a
categorical denial that anything's going
to happen I think lots of things are in
play I think Quassy crossing looks
uncomfortable I think people inside
Downing Street are perhaps trying to
make decisions on his behalf we don't
know how this is going to end we don't
have the personality politics and the uh
and the political tensions are going to
play out so we're just gonna have to
wait and see Sir James actually that's
it personality politics but he said my
position hasn't changed do you think now
we're seeing a bit of a split between
what the chancellor thinks and perhaps
what the prime minister is now thinking
and that's quite dangerous isn't it
especially this early on between the PM
and her Chancellor
well let's let's focus in on what we
know we know that there are advisors to
the Prime Minister according to this
morning's times who are saying do a
massive U-turn and we also know that
there have been points of tension in the
relationship between Liz truss uh and
quasiquarting so go back a two weeks I
think it is there was uh Liz truss
resisting attempts by crazy quieting to
respond to a bank of England statement
about uh uh about problems in the market
eventually he got her to do that but
that that was a moment of tension I
think uh there was the kerfuffle over
who should be the lead civil servant in
the treasury in the end uh Liz truss
overruled quasi quatting over who that
should be uh to install her own
candidate somebody uh James bowler who
she's personally close to I think there
are all sorts of other more techy things
that they have not been necessarily on
the same page on and then you come to
that U-turn that's already happened
about the top right attacks the 150 000
pound people letting over 150 000 pounds
um scrapping the additional rate that's
now been reinstated Liz truss went on
the Telly and said that was the
Chancellor's decision so I think I think
seeing a pattern of you know you can
call it tension you can call it
disagreement it is not terribly settling
for the markets to have the chancellor
pulling in One Direction and the Prime
Minister seeming to be in a slightly
different place and and and to be honest
and we're having to read a little bit
behind a lot but between the lines we
have to sort of work out from a bit of
the nuances because stuff isn't
announced yet it feels like that's
exactly the territory that we're in
again after that not particularly
relaxed encounter in Washington yeah
well we'll see who wins that tug of war
between the chance of the Prime Minister
potentially before the 31st of October
Sam thank you Sam coats there our Deputy
political editor